- YouTube, what's up?
So so grateful that you clicked
and you're about to watch
a new YouTube video,
but before you do, 212-931-5731;
that is my texting community platform.
I'm doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there,
and also access, opportunity,
first looks in that environment.
212-931-5731, join it now.
And now to the video you've
been wanting to watch.
We have so much time.
I just wish that people had a
better relationship with time.
(upbeat music)
You've got your perspective.
(crowd cheering)
I just want to be happy.
(upbeat electronic music)
I'm actually really excited,
even though we've been traveling.
We flew from New York to Dallas;
Dallas to Monterey, Mexico;
Mexico to Saint Paulo right?
Oh, no, Monterey to Mexico City;
Mexico City to Saint
Paulo; Saint Paulo to here.
- That's crazy
- Now this, and then we run
right back to the airport.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
What is up?
What's good?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you for having me.
Brazil, how are you?
- [Woman] What can I, as
a mom, do for my kids?
- Sure, so I think business
and parenting have a lot of similarities,
so when I hear those kinds
of stories, and I'm sure--
How many people here are parents?
Raise your hands.
So, for all the hands that just went up,
you know how challenging it is, like,
you could have common
sense everywhere else,
but when it's your kids,
it's hard to maintain it,
but I believe that self-esteem
is the ultimate cure to everything,
and I think most parents go on defense
when their kids are
hurting instead of offense.
So when their kids are bullied, they want
to go fight the school; they want
to go fight the parent of the kid.
It's defense.
For me, as somebody who was bullied,
because, you know, I was a
Soviet immigrant in America
in my childhood when the
Soviet Union was the enemy.
There was plenty of shit, I mean,
if you could zoom in, I've got goosebumps.
It was a very challenging
time, but what my mom did was,
she went insular, it was offense.
It was me and her in my own
head hearing nothing else.
By the time I was in high school,
I couldn't hear anybody else.
It didn't matter.
By the way, both pro and con.
So for me, I think a thing you can do
is beat into their head about that,
not about the people in
Montreal or Toronto or Canada.
It's not about them, it's about yourself
inside your own head, your own self-worth,
and you have to pound it.
A lot of parents, you're
like, "Oh, easy to say,"
but when their kids are
right, you're right.
But it's no different than
working out and eating healthy.
It's no different than making content
and putting it on all the platforms.
The answer is simple.
Pound into your kid's
head their own self-worth,
not the opinions of others.
They'll be a happy
person their whole life.
The problem is, most parents
aren't acting that way.
So it's hard for them to give advice
that they don't even feel themselves,
but that is the answer.
- [Woman] So me and my sister
are starting a JV film.
I know we're not putting as many content
as we should out there.
- [Gary] Why?
Why do you think?
Talk to me real.
We're here.
Why?
- Well, she lives in another town,
so it's a little difficult for us to--
- [Gary] Well you don't have
to both be in the content.
- Yeah, and she doesn't
have a lot of confidence.
She's really good.
- [Gary] She knows her craft.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] So what about writing?
(phone ringing)
Hey, guys.
Sorry to interrupt your video.
I'm just giving you
this call from my number
to let you know that you have
to join my text community.
212-931-5731 Hit me up with a text.
Or what about audio?
I feel like so many people
that don't have confidence
are very scared of the camera,
but can do much much better
writing or recording audio.
This is why I spent so
much time on it in my talk.
I don't want people to be like me.
Now listen, not everybody is
ridiculously handsome and charismatic.
(crowd laughing)
You know what I mean though?
I don't want people to be like me.
I want people to be like me where they
found their voice in their media.
But for a lot of you in
this room, that's writing.
You know, if you're more
introverted or insecure,
a lot of writers come from that framework.
I really like audio, so keep that in mind.
- Maybe this is the reality
for a lot of people here.
When you're in a city where a lot
of people don't think the same way we do,
they don't see the things that we see.
- Story of my fucking life.
- Like, they need that product,
they need that service,
but they don't want it.
So it takes up a lot of our time.
How can we improve that?
- Don't try to convince anybody.
The number one mistake when
you're selling something
new that most people don't understand
is people spend too much
trying to convince them,
instead of finding the person
that already understands.
People make it a noble
mission instead of a business.
My friend, I've been right and early
for the last 20 years of my life.
I've spent almost no time
trying to convince anybody.
I sometimes have a one hour
meeting with a company,
fly from New York to
Chicago, walk in, sit down,
start the presentation, and
end it after ten minutes
because I already know it's over.
Every minute that you spend trying
to convince somebody who's a ready "no"
is a minute that you're not spending
trying to find somebody that will say yes.
- So, I've been, for a
couple months maybe years,
trying to figure out if I
have to leave my small town
or just stay there, be patient,
wait for my business to be big.
Would you imagine
yourself, as a business man
at the size that you are right now,
staying in my small town?
- I understand.
So, the question for you
and everybody here is,
"What's big?"
Right?
Because this is where people get caught.
It's so simple being in a small town
in Argentina thinking you
have to go to Saint Paulo,
or you have to go to Buenos Aires,
or you have to go to New York City.
It's easy.
You're like, "that's a
much bigger place to go."
The question is, it comes
down to what makes you happy.
For me, what makes me
happy is to play the game;
not the money, not how big or small.
I just want to play.
I've always wanted to play.
I've watched so many people have
a one million dollar
business in a small town
in America or in the world,
move to a bigger place,
do five million, and be very unhappy.
They were very happy at one
million in their small town.
They went to a bigger
town, they do ten million,
and they're very unhappy.
My friend, Brazil, it is time that we
in the world start making happiness
what we go after, not more money.
(crowd cheering and clapping)
We have to.
Right?
For me, when I hear "bigger" I want you
to have a bigger fucking
smile on your pretty face,
not make two-hundred eighty thousand more
in fucking net revenue.
You understand?
You have to decide that for yourself.
I don't know you.
- He said, "The biggest thing that hit him
was when you said, 'What are the
three most important words
that you're going to have?'."
- You're gonna die.
Yeah, I mean, brother, my biggest hope
for everybody is to not have regret.
Besides health, health which you need,
I want people to have happiness and
as much happiness and as little regret.
You know, you're such a young man.
We have so much time.
I just wish that people had a
better relationship with time.
There's so much more time.
So, I'm glad that that hit you,
because it's very real.
Everything I do,
everything, is knowing that
it's almost impossible
to be a human being.
Four-hundred trillion to one.
That is the math.
The odds of being
somebody in here right now
is four-hundred trillion to one.
It's impossible to be
a human being, and yet,
everybody here is one, and I don't
want you to waste it, why?
(upbeat rap music)
Hello, hello.
Thank you.
I love you.
Hello.
Hi.
How are you?
This one?
Yup, no problem.
How are you?
Thank you, brother.
- Let me ask you a quick question.
- Please.
- I have a eCommerce agency, 45 people,
what would you focus on right now?
- Shopify is winning globally.
Influencer marketing
to conversion of sales.
Text.
I'm seeing incredible
results in eCommerce in text.
- Awesome, man.
Take care.
- Stay well, good luck.
(man speaking in foreign language)
- [Crowd] ♪ Happy birthday to you. ♪
- [Gary] That's so sweet.
- [Crowd] ♪ Happy birthday, dear Gary. ♪
♪ Happy birthday to you. ♪
- [Gary] Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Thank you, Brazil.
Thank you so much for having me.
(upbeat rap music)
- [Man In Red] I fucking love you, man.
- I love you back, thank you, my friend.
(mug breaks on floor)
Oh.
- That's okay.
I got it.
That's good luck.
- [Man In Red] Is it really good luck?
- No.
Yeah, I usually like it on my right side
'cause I'm righty, but
this is my left side.
- [Man] Well, I like it that way.
- Are you lefty?
- [Man] Yeah.
- Most great creatives are.
And you.
- [Announcer] Gary T.
- Chee?
(unintelligible rapping)
This is super neat.
It's really cool.
2019, see ya.
(upbeat music)